Josh Weissman has completely changed the
restaurant industry by taking everything
they do and then making it better and
cheaper today we're getting an inside
look on the secrets of the restaurant
industry they definitely do illegal [ __ ]
in that in that world how you're able to
make the best meals on a budget and how
he was able to turn his passion for
cooking into a multi-million dollar
business but first we gotta thank our
sponsor Aura as you might have noticed a
lot of our guests have always talked
about the importance of getting a good
night of sleep and I always thought that
I was sleeping just fine until Aura sent
me their sleep tracking ring and then I
realized how bad of a sleeper I guess I
am and how many times I'm waking up in
the middle of the night so being able to
track my sleep has been incredibly
important and now I know exactly how
much sleep I need when I'm most likely
to wake up and how I could optimize that
just to feel better during the day see I
always knew I was a bad sleeper but
finally I can have a log of when I wake
up throughout the night and how I can
improve on my sleep and since I've got
the aura ring and been able to track
these stats I've been able to
drastically improve my sleep there are
hundreds of studies out there that
directly correlate good sleep with
product activity but good sleep is a lot
more complicated than the hours from
when you lay down until the time you
wake up sleep is broken down into four
different stages and Aura gives you a
detailed breakdown of how much each
stage you're getting and what you could
do to improve they also track your heart
rate heart rate variability and oxygen
levels when you sleep or also has tons
of other cool features like activity
tracking temperature variations and more
so check out Aura with the link Down
Below in the description thank you so
much or for sponsoring this episode and
back to the podcast enjoy welcome back
to the iced coffee hour I'm Joshua
Weissman and I cook food
welcome what brings you out to Vegas
I was doing a little cooking thing with
uh I don't know if you guys know Jean
George uh he's like a huge so I mean a
juggernaut in the chef's space this
guy's on I don't even know how he's
managed to do what he does but he has
multiple Michelin star restaurants he
has like 50 or 60 restaurants now I
studied him a bunch when I was a kid and
they randomly reached out I was like hey
John George like watches you you want to
hang out and like do some stuff and so
we came out and filmed the video it was
super fun can you tell us about the
video Yeah Yeah so basically the concept
was can I beat a Michelin Chef uh so we
did like chopping competitions and like
a bunch of other things and we made like
a plate I had to like come up with a
dish he he got to use one of the dishes
that was already at the restaurant so I
felt a little disadvantaged there but I
came with a dish and like put it
together and we went head to head and
you'll have to watch the video to see
what happens who judges that though uh
we had uh a bunch of blindfolded taste
testers come in and pick a dish it was a
steak dish how do you think you did
going into it like before I got there
yeah before well before he got judged
like after he made the meal ah you know
I hate to say it because everybody's
usually like God Josh has a big e oh
you're right I walked in feeling just
fine but you know I think that I will
say that I think that there is an
element to like being successful in a
scenario like that right in the same way
with athletes too right I'm not saying
that I'm you know back to like an
athlete if I can run like two minutes
and I'm done but I think the mentality
aspect helps me do well in scenarios
like that you know high pressure but um
I don't know I felt fine I felt like I
was going to do well I didn't know if I
would win or not but I didn't really
care because it's like this guy's been
cooking professionally and has had his
own restaurant an entire Restaurant
Group for like 50 years
so how old is this guy he's 60. okay and
what does it mean Michelin star what is
I I always hear it but I have honestly
no idea what that means really yeah so
it's kind of a it's kind of a weird
mysterious thing so
we know Michelin tires it comes from the
tire company guys is it real sorry it
does it does it does it's 100 the exact
same company so I will say that there's
a little bit of a weird element to it
but I think it took off where Michelin
started a guide where they're like okay
we sell tires we want to incentivize
selling tires this is my assumption in
their boardroom meeting here and they
say they decided okay well we'll make a
system where
we'll give a bunch of recommendations of
great places to eat and bed and
breakfast and whatnot for you to stop at
a longer trip using Michelin tires no
and that was kind of the the whole
element of it
but it became its own thing so this is
why I still respect it to an extent it
became its own thing because
people started Desiring these sort of
unattainable ratings where it was like
one two three stars right and then it
kind of fell into fine dining where it
was you know one star is just for great
food two stars is great food and great
service three stars is like everything
it's like the Symphony of a restaurant
being utterly perfect from the bottom to
the top someone drops a napkin it gets
picked up within a certain amount of
time if somebody like you know the forks
and knives are always placed in the
right spot every single time
um did the waiter a waitress check on
you and when they checked on you how did
they check on you and like it that's
just a fraction of the level of
intricacy that they look for
um and so it ended up becoming this
really sort of difficult to acquire
award and human beings love that so uh
you know everybody's like oh well I want
a Michelin star I'd love to have one as
well so I mean I get it have you been to
a three Michelin star restaurant yes uh
I've been to a couple different ones
there's one I don't know if they still
have three stars there's one in San
Francisco called Cezanne
so expensive yeah yeah how much easily
eat without drinks like 750 a person no
750 I'm pretty sure yeah I'm pretty I'm
pretty sure they're the most expensive
Michelin restaurant in America because
most on I think their average tab is
like a thousand
person or something like that person
yeah what do you get for a thousand
dollars I mean it depends on where you
go but with oh with Cezanne um yeah so I
mean you're gonna get like
multiple multiple courses not five
courses or six courses probably closer
to 12 or maybe even 15 you might be
dining for three or four hours are you
serious your ass will get sweaty I'll
tell you right now can I say that on the
spot yeah it's okay uh great news so
yeah I mean some of these restaurants
actually have rest areas so you'll go in
and I I love it personally it is God is
what it is it is honestly really fun
what this is it's kind of like a spa you
know you go to a spa right and it's kind
of unnecessarily catered to you in a way
where it's like they lift your arm and
do everything for you and they lift your
arm for you no no no no no I'm I'm I'm
bringing up the concept of a spot
imagine imagine the server just chewing
the food board and then they baby yeah
yeah exactly exactly and then they give
you like a gift card now
um so the concept is like you're catered
to and every women in most scenarios so
like there are some places where you'd
go and you'd eat for maybe an hour and
then they'd go okay cool now you're
gonna go over to the Espresso Bar so
I'll move you over this rest area
there's some couches like really nice
modern couches maybe they have like
something to read or whatever they give
you a small espresso and then maybe like
a juice or something refreshing sit
there for about 10 minutes then they'll
escort you back to your table and then
your tables reset with different plates
and different silverware for the next
set of courses
like it's like high high high fine
dining how often do people go to a
restaurant like that is that like a once
a month sort of deal if you have the
money or is like once a year that sounds
exhausting to me yeah
I think it's more of like something you
go and do every once in a while you know
you go go-karting every once in a while
you go to the fancy restaurant every
once in a while so our most three-star
Michelin restaurants like that where
they have rest areas or is that just a
one-off I would say that's a that's not
most of them okay most of them are like
you know they're restaurants but they're
just really really high level food or
really high level Cuisine there's
usually other elements to it though I
mean another comparison I could make is
um I remember the name of it 11 Madison
are you guys familiar with it yeah yeah
it's actually one of the largest three
Michelin star restaurants in the world
typically
higher quality less seats they want
consistency they're going to have less
seats most Michelin restaurants are like
40 seats and under because they just
don't want to deal with like having to
do food like that yeah 11 has like a
couple like I think 150 200 something
like that they have 70 people on the
line
70 people
or it might be 50 or 70 something like
that some ridiculous amount yeah of
people that are cooking but their
experience is very much like catered to
you like sometimes I think one of my
friends went and his dad is like knows
the community there pretty well he went
in and they were talking about F1 and
they were having their meal and it was
based off the menu nothing too crazy and
it was like a like a 10 course menu or
something like that all vegetables and
the waiter overheard them talking about
F1 and so for their dessert they got a
bunch of F1 inspired desserts and then
got a F1 cookie of like a bunch of F1
cars like as a gift to leave with in a
little gift bag isn't that the place
where they like they ask you about
yourself and you tell them like your
interests or whatever and then they can
because I swear I heard about a Michelin
star restaurant that will like go figure
out your interest so they know that they
can converse with you about certain
topics I've actually never eaten at 11.
I'm I'm only talking about someone
else's experience I'm not 100 sure but I
mean sure I wouldn't be surprised if
they did that but the point is like each
experience is going to be different
depending on the restaurant you go to
you know some places might have a rest
area some places might just be a
restaurant and the food is insane you
know the French Laundry you go and you
eat you leave but they usually give you
like gifts and stuff like that when you
leave and how much do the employees make
do you know at these nothing
really yeah I mean you know
I I'm gonna kind of get in the
conversation of experience is is you
know what I mean I back in the day when
I was working you know as a young line
cook I would have taken pretty much any
pay to work at any of these places and
that's how most people feel but you'll
find that there's not a ton of people
that are able to do that because
affordability right a lot of the people
that are working at these places have
one of two or three things either one
they have good friends that they can
sleep on their couch and stuff like that
two they have money saved up and they
can pay rent or or maybe they are paid
well it's getting better there are
places that pay enough to afford rent
but third the higher the restaurant some
sometimes they'll pay much less than you
could imagine
and most people can't afford rent uh
like I wanted to work at this one
restaurant the champion named uh this
was years and years and years ago
um three Michelin star in San Francisco
and they actually gave me a job offer
because one of my old chefs knew them
and he was like oh this guy's talented
like he likes your restaurant you should
consider him and they gave me an offer
but they were like well first you need
to stash and stashing is like a unpaid
internship you come in for like a day or
two and show them what you got and then
you leave and then they decide if
they're gonna hire you right they said
the stage is two months
two months no pay zero they wanted me to
work four days a week
and stage two months in San Francisco as
a line cook how is that legal they just
call it something different like an
internship I have no clue okay I have no
clue they definitely do illegal [ __ ] in
that in that world okay it is getting
better and it's been getting cracked
down on I would say okay so that's the
good part um but yeah so that gives you
an example of kind of like what most of
the people are going to be getting paid
anywhere from 12 to maybe 17 an hour wow
but the servers make probably a lot
right because they're tips yeah
sometimes they share tips but it's rare
if they're not sharing tips then yeah
servers make Bank service can make six
figures
yeah pretty pretty easily yeah we know a
few servers here on the Strip who would
easily make about 150 maybe as high as
200 000 a year just working at a really
high-end restaurant some of the tabs are
insane we went out to dinner last night
I'm not gonna share where but uh you
know where but the table across from us
got a 5300 bottle the 5300 bottle of
sake just one bottle fifty three hundred
dollars that's insane yeah so you can
imagine the tip on top of that plus Food
Plus other drinks plus everything else
just two people yeah especially if it's
like a large party that's when it gets
crazy in some of these restaurants one
of the restaurants I worked at there was
uh I think it was like a 20 top that
came in so 20 20 seats 20 people sitting
in seats
um and they ordered all of the most
expensive [ __ ] and the most expensive
bottles of like wine and champagne
let me tell you something whatever
you're paying for champagne and wine at
these restaurants
is like five to six hundred percent of
what it actually is there was a bottle
uh one of the restaurants that were and
I like I like the champagne but it's
sold at the grocery store for
well actually I'll tell you what we sold
it for first all right so the restaurant
sold it for 75 a bottle which is like
not exorbitant that's affordable for
some people but
at the store it's at twelve dollars
twelve dollars at the store selling it
for 75 so but
um is that why they charge the corkage
fees so if you bring your own in yes
okay so bring your own wine in a lot of
times yeah yeah and they'll charge
corkage fees so they're usually like 30
bucks so it could be more than the cost
it would take just does that go for a
bottle or is that like per table
it's like if you bring in like three
bottles I believe it's per bottle yeah
wrong yeah so it's worth it if you bring
in a really expensive bottle like a 500
bottle then you'll save a lot of money
most restaurants are profitable are
profitable because of alcohol
that's why most of them I'm not saying
that that's the only reason I'm just
saying that the reason why they pass
over margins and get like at least a
decent payout is alcohol because food is
tough to make profitable it's very hard
you have to balance your menu there's
like how much is your food cost what's
your overhead etc etc how long does it
take to make some of these things a lot
of fine dining places uh are not
profitable like there's a lot of
michelin-starred restaurants that are
not profitable but there's just somebody
who has a lot of money that owns it wow
but you know what before we go into that
I want to say a huge thank you to our
sponsor of stream yard you know in the
beginning stages when it comes to making
content one of the best ways to figure
out what works is to create as much as
possible and reducing that time is
essential so you have more time left
over to figure out what works best well
thankfully stream yard is one of the
best ways to produce high quality
content right from your browser
streamyard is a live streaming Studio
platform perfect for people looking to
get into content creation without having
to worry about all the editing setup and
post-production that comes with it you
can stream directly to Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and several other platforms
they also make it easy to brand and
customize your videos before you even go
live in addition to that they allow you
to multi-stream social media platforms
so you can maximize your content's reach
whether you want to start live streaming
or just easily record new content stream
yard makes it simple to get polished and
professional content every single time
so if you want to get started but you
don't want to waste countless hours on
production setup and editing we couldn't
recommend stream yard anymore so get
started for free today by using the link
Down Below in the description and start
creating high quality content as soon as
you finish the podcast of course so
again the link is down below in the
description and now let's get back to
this podcast let's talk a little bit
about your personal background and your
experience with being a chef where did
you first find interest in cooking and
uh yeah a little bit about the timeline
yeah you know it's funny I I feel like a
lot of people don't believe me but I
started cooking when I was like
four like four or five probably like
legitimately cooking regularly my mom
brought me and my mom cooks a lot she's
from the south you know chicken fried
steak and she's making ribs and she's
making cream gravy and this and stuff
and you know she's amazing really a very
very very talented cook uh and so that
interested me it was the one place I
could go and make a mess there's one
place I could go make a mess and just
kind of like you know pick up a knife
and Shop in in what other scenario as a
kid can you do that right everywhere
else everybody tells you no but the
kitchen's the one place you could do
that so that was exciting to me
um so I started doing that for a little
bit and my mom could tell I took
interest in it so she kept kind of like
fueling the fire she gave me a little
knife she gave me like a cutting board
and
um I think at around 10 I was like this
is definitely my thing because I was
good at it pretty much right out the
gate
um
and
it's funny I feel like especially now
actually like 10 year olds are very
self-conscious about what they're going
to be doing and what they're going to be
I don't know if you guys have like
interviewed a 10 year old but not yet
but like been around kids though where
they're talking like you know my my
fiance's uh cousins and stuff and and uh
nieces and nephews like the way that
they talk I'm like they're really
stressed out about their future you're
like 10 bro
um I was as well and so
to me I was like I'm not good at a lot
of other things I'm really good at this
this is definitely my thing and from
then on I had decided I was like I'm
gonna figure out how to make this into
something
um that is good so by 10 you had that
figured out yeah what was it about
cooking that Drew you to that I think it
was
it was the element of something that I
knew that I was way better at adults
and I knew you know my the age Gap my
mind kind of went there I think that
there's something here and I want to be
good at something and I wasn't good at
video games thank god
um and that was like the main draws that
I enjoyed it so much and there was never
a time that I was bored and I was good
at it and I knew that then and I was I
think I didn't want to waste time trying
to look for something else like oh is
there something better out there my mind
was like I could do this forever and
always be happy so why would I do
anything how did your parents Foster
that growth were they encouraging of you
like making your own lunch or cooking
dinners that's a good question they were
extremely supportive I mean I mean you
kind of behooved them right because I
cooked them dinner like every night but
I didn't love that yeah but I'll give
I'll give you some examples as to how
they nurtured it though because they
definitely did like more so than they
had to they spent a lot of money on like
unnecessary expensive things like
kitchen knives and fanciest equipment
that I use like once and then threw in
the garage I was like oh cool a weird
little juicer thing and then never used
it again on my 16th birthday you know
got my license and all that
and I I asked they're like oh what do
you want what do you want to get you
know for your 16th birthday and I was
like I just want like a whole pig
and my mom was like
no absolutely not like not I mean she
was like cool with it in the sense of I
guess but she really didn't want to deal
with it she's like all right let me see
if I can find something else my dad went
ahead and got it and then so she didn't
know and I'm like in the kitchen and my
mom walked there's like six or seven p.m
my mom was like out doing other stuff
she comes in and I'm like Midway like
with a bone saw no cutting the leg off
this pig it's dead for the record
everybody just so you know
um you buy a pig like a full form Pig
yeah
at all or no it's well usually okay yeah
usually it would be you can't uh Magic
just plop it down like from an animal
Butchery standpoint you cannot show up
with like an un taken care of pig
because like you have to kind of like
get that stuff out of there you don't
want to look outside yeah so it was
already like gutted and everything and
like the hair was like but not torched
off
no is it the hair was torched off yeah
so it was like burnt and it was bald
it's like a naked giant naked mole rat
gutted yeah basically and that was your
16th birthday present yeah yeah
um but why did you want a pig so I
wanted to learn how to do whole animal
Butchery I think you know at 16 I had
done a lot of research by then 10 at
from 10 to 16 I was like doing
exorbitant amounts of research I bought
every book I could possibly buy I read
every single one of them several times I
tried as many I probably cooked like
geez like two or three different things
out of a book every day from 10 to 16.
um I say every day you know maybe there
were a couple days where I didn't but
the point is it was it was a lot uh and
I realized I was like man how are people
you know butchering these animals Google
it well animal Butchery oh cool there's
all this information well how am I
supposed to put this to you so that a
whole pig that was basically it whole
Pig's expensive it was like a thousand
dollars a thousand dollars for a pickup
it was like a Heritage breed home why do
you need a Heritage breed hog is that
just like a better quality meat yeah way
better quality meat um and then also
just like I don't know sustained ability
and I I don't know if you're gonna like
break down a whole pig do you really
want like a quality pig or do you want
like the nice stuff you know some nice
high quality flavor good intramuscular
fat and all that stuff how do you cook
such a big pig is there like a special
I'm curious about that you can't put
that gram is really in with that in the
oven I'm just trying to visualize yeah
you just slap that [ __ ] in the oven and
it's done yeah no you can't I'm just
completely you cannot oh dude this thing
would take up this whole table have you
you cannot hear I'll tell you this you
can't pick this thing up by yourself
unless you're you're really strong it's
like carrying a dead body not that I
know what that's like yeah for the
record so how did you cut it did you put
it on a table and like yeah so I had to
take two huge actually it was I took
four huge um like but you know those
Butcher Block boards the really big ones
yeah and like basically shingled them
all together put the pig on it
and then you know I you know I have to
kind of like break all the limbs down
take the legs
take the head all the other things and
then you start breaking down the Primal
cuts of meat which like those really big
pizzas so pork chop comes from a whole
Primal cut of meat it's like an entire
um like there's multiple chines of Bones
and it's like this entire roast that you
slice pork chops from yeah same thing
with beef that's basically it so I broke
it down into like different cuts and we
got my parents had to buy a chest
freezer to put it all in there so you
can see how supportive they were I mean
like most parents in that scenario would
be like
no absolutely not so they dealt with a
lot for me uh to make that happen was
that hard for you at all to like like
actually be visually seeing like because
personally for me I know
if I had to like kill or like look at
the food me too before it was actually
just a stake on my plate I know it
sounds so terrible I know a lot of
people also like feel this way I
wouldn't be able to eat it all right
totally I don't think so I totally get
it I've seen the pig the pig head yeah
and seeing the meat too I can't do it
because I see the pig yeah it's it's
funny
I think that makes complete sense I
think that's also like a very natural
human reaction I also felt that way but
it's sort of like you have a goal and
you're gonna grind to get to that goal
and so my my mentality was like man this
is a lot when I first saw it initially
there was a little bit of a shock factor
I mean it's an animal but in my mind I'm
like look I really want to get good at
this like I have to learn this stuff and
I have to know how this works I how can
I how can I call myself like a
professional that cares about what I do
and not know where these things come
from how to care for them and I will say
one thing it's built up the respect that
I have for the food when I cook it
that's why I I don't that when I'm
cooking like my initial thought is this
came from an animal animal had to die
for this and there's there's a whole
sort of Ethics behind being you know a
chef so to speak and I think giving
respect to the ingredients is only going
to be earned when you really see that
and you understand that so there's that
aspect and
but you know I was willing to deal with
it to learn it
um but I won't say that I loved it you
know it's not like I was there like you
know just pick up like with a smile on
my face I was definitely there were some
parts where I was just like man this is
a little bit much taking the head off
was was rough it was tough for me the
first time I did it after a while you
get desensitized and you don't really
care that I'll say like if you start
butchering cool animals in a restaurant
which I I never did
um but there were there were a couple
restaurants I worked for that did whole
animal Butchery and you see it so often
that when someone slings a pig over
their shoulder two guys sling Pig over
their shoulder then carry it in it's not
really a big deal you know you see it
every single year but one of my first
restaurants that I worked and I walked
in
and they had a whole pig that they had
roasted the whole thing and uh
and one of the line Cooks comes up to me
and he had the head in its hand after it
was roasted and he's like
he's like look man we just roasted this
and I was like oh uh I literally just
got it it's a little too much for me
right now man and then the jaw just kind
of went like and then it fell off and I
was just like oh my God oh my God so
yeah yikes all right so welcome to
horror hour how long did it take you to
eat the whole pig I I imagine that you
just served this over many weeks
probably months really yeah there's a
lot there was a lot and I mean we froze
it all yeah
um so some of it I made like bacon like
cured the pork belly and like smoked it
and sliced it and made like actual like
bacon
um I tried to cure the legs they didn't
really work
um we wrote we made one of the legs into
a ham like a giant like ham
um and yeah it took probably a few
months like six months okay a lot and
then what about throughout High School
were you working part-time at
restaurants or were you just doing all
of this for fun recreationally it was
all recreationally I would cook for my
parents my friends but it did get to a
point where I wanted to work in
restaurants and they they don't like
it's a big problem in the industry with
like underage
uh labor you know because like kids
would come in and peel carrots like oh
it's so fun can't do that anymore so I
had to wait until I was like 18 to work
in restaurants when I moved to Austin
was when I started working and then yeah
that was pretty seamless transition of
like the one thing I was doing when I
was a kid that I could get work doing is
I was doing like food photography stuff
anything I could do to get my hands on
to making money working in food I would
do like food photography uh for mag like
small magazines or ebooks
um I'd help people do recipe development
I'd write recipes for people edit
recipes sometimes I would come on to
sets and like be a studio assistant to
style food
um anything I could do and what was your
first job it was working a restaurant
just like uh what like a line cook or
something uh usually your first time you
start as a prep cook so you're like
chopping loads of vegetables when I say
a lot I mean like a lot like 100 pounds
of onions or like you know there was um
300 oranges and then you take the
oranges and you peel every single one of
them with a knife and then you remove
each individual segment from the orange
but 300 of them though yeah this might
seem like a silly question if you've
ever taken a cooking lesson or wanted to
go to like a cooking college or like a
school for this like a culinary school
so actually I never went to school or
college oh well let me rephrase that I
never went to college yeah I didn't go
to culinary school either
I I mean you know it gets to a point
where I was just like
do I really need my parents to spend a
hundred thousand dollars for me to go to
culinary school
um but I also tried applying to a couple
of them and they all denied me why is
that I don't know
um I tried going to there was one that I
wanted I guess I shouldn't name them but
I applied to someone like the most
esteemed culinary schools that there are
because I was like I'm I'm good like I
can go here uh and then I applied to
some other ones that were local and I
actually applied to a couple colleges
too I did not want to go to either of
them but I did it anyway because my
parents were like oh come on you know
they weren't pushing me too much but
they were like you know let's let's do
it and all the colleges uh did not admit
me and none of the culinary schools
admitted me and I was just like
so where do I go and my parents are like
oh we'll just apply to some more and
then I was like
honestly I'm good and totally broke my
mom's heart because my mom hasn't had
anyone uh you know on her side that's
really gotten the chance to do that and
um she would have been the first and so
she wanted me to do it and so it was
kind of tough for a little bit for her
but she let you know she they didn't
fight me on it which was cool I really
appreciated that and that also goes to
show like how much support comes into
role uh into play here with this but
yeah I mean didn't go to college or
culinary school for that reason wow and
so what was your experience then going
from high school to then working
full-time in the industry did that make
it less fun for you knowing that it's
now a job no I felt like I was getting
paid to learn it was awesome yeah I mean
granted I was getting paid like nine
dollars seven seven to nine dollars an
hour and I was like why can't I pay rent
this is confusing I work like 90 hours a
week but all right I'm gonna you know I
was a kid yeah I think in between then I
took like a little bit of time off I
went to Europe for like two and a half
months with all the money that I had
saved up
um and just went around and ate as much
as I could gather as much knowledge as I
could I went into a couple like
restaurants and worked in the back house
for a day as a stash in France actually
um super mean very mean they did not
like that I didn't speak French which I
get I get that
um and then when I got back I think I
started actually you know what there's
there's one piece a story that I forgot
to mention which is I was doing a food
blog at the time
um just for fun and it started doing
pretty well and then I randomly got a
book deal from this really small
publisher and I was like all right okay
I was 17 at the time and so I was I was
really just doing that it did all right
it was like you know nobody really knows
about it now they know about it now but
back then nobody really knew about it
um and then from there after that I
pretty much spent all of my money when I
moved to Austin like all of it I didn't
have that that much I think I had like
saved up 12 Grand
went to Europe spent half of that I
don't know how I managed to do that in
two months I have no idea lived off that
okay
um and then spent the rest of it in
Austin had zero dollars and I was like
time to get a job and went to
restaurants Wow and you somehow afforded
rent on like seven what was it like
eight bucks an hour yeah so the first
one was I think it was around eight or
nine dollars an hour
um
I don't know well the rent was actually
really low it was this pretty rinky
dinky like old house and I think the
rent was
man I could be wrong but I think it was
like 750. it's pretty low
um for especially for Austin that's
really low
yeah now that it would be what like
eighteen hundred dollars oh it's easy oh
my God
yeah troll yeah it'd easily be like it'd
probably be like 12 12 or 1500 now
um but yeah I I just didn't spend money
on anything else you know I ate all the
food that I needed to eat at the
restaurant and then when I got home I I
might have like some cheap things that I
could make like pasta
um and then it got to a point where my
my girlfriend at the time now fiance
would help me pay rent which if you're
wondering that's why she's my fiance now
pass the test yeah pass the test I mean
you know I don't think it's required to
pay your essos rent but she helped a
bunch so that's cool then where did the
concept come for your YouTube channel so
I'm trying to remember how that's
basically when I was working I I'd gone
through working through a few different
restaurants lots of fine dining
um I got my experience I was getting
good and I was getting like known in the
community and I was knowing a bunch of
the chefs and restaurants and
um I was kind of getting veering towards
like a sous chef position uh at the
current restaurant once you get a sous
chef position it's very hard to leave
because it's not like you can't quit but
it's just the attachment of like how
much work work it takes to get to that
point you want to like write it out
and there's just a certain emotional
attachment I was afraid of that because
I was like man if I do this I'm not
going to be able to do some of the other
things that I wanted which those things
were I wanted to work I wanted to do
like television or shows and visual
entertainment essentially because I felt
that I did not like the shows that were
being put out I thought they were
terrible I thought it wasn't doing food
Justice and like there's so much
exciting stuff out there and I felt that
food entertainment was slowly losing the
people and that freaked me out because
that also was about as equally important
to me as the cooking was that was
something a passion that I grew over
time my dad's like in film and or was he
was in film for a number of years and so
that was something that I thought was
really important and so I wanted to
contribute to that too
and I'm like how am I supposed to do
that working as a line cook uh or turn
on at the time going into a sous chef
position how am I supposed to do that
working 80 to 90 hours a week how am I
supposed to have time for that and I was
like well I mean I could start on
YouTube I could like make a couple
videos and like edit them at night and
or in the morning instead
um and call it a day and maybe we'll see
where that goes and maybe I can use that
to do other stuff and uh
for a year I slept
I think four hours a night every single
night in order to do that because there
was no other way I could find time yeah
because think about it I go you go into
the restaurant if you're working
mornings you go in the restaurant you
get up at five and you shower get ready
get there at 6 30 or 7. you prep you
work until probably 5 30 or 6 and then
you get home it's night time and then
you eat and you rinse and repeat but
typically you would stay after until
like seven sometimes I would stay until
seven to like learn right but if you're
on the line then you come in and you
come in instead at like maybe they say
noon or one yeah you need to come in at
10 if you want to set up your station on
time so really you come in at 10. 10 to
1 in the morning or two in the morning
10 a.m to 20.
so then your window of time at 1am you
get home by let's say two after you
close your station and everything like
that you get home at say 1 30 or 2.
we'll say 1 30 for posterity 1 30 in the
morning
you get to bed at like two
so two three four five six seven you get
up at seven eight nine ten you have two
hours to get to the restaurant get your
knives sharpen your knives press your
Chef coat
go to the bathroom work out
um so I basically had anywhere between a
two and four hour window to get anything
done for the YouTube channel and the
only way to extract like to expand that
for editing was I was like I'll just
sleep less
it gives me three more hours a day so
they gave me six hours a day to do work
so that's kind of what the process was
to get to that point
um and yeah what were the first few
videos that you decided to film it
started out kind of wonky you can you
can go back and see some of my old
videos in the apartment that I was at
and I just like found some shitty lights
and turned it on I think I think I was
trying to give like Chef techniques away
I was like okay this is how you like set
up for cooking and you know make your
kitchen efficient and you can do this
and that they were really boring and
really slow and poorly edited but my
idea in my head was like well maybe I
can give people the information the
secret stuff that nobody gives away all
the all these chefs are very secretive
you know they don't want to talk about
the techniques in the restaurant
industry and I was like well I don't
give a [ __ ] you're paying me nine
dollars an hour I'll say whatever I want
yeah and so that's where I started what
were some of the secrets you were giving
away things that people wouldn't
normally know because they're not in
cookbooks and you're not going to Google
certain nowadays you kind of can because
like more and more people are talking
about it but you back in the day you
couldn't Google some of these techniques
people didn't even know they existed
just little things like the Finesse and
the way that you operate so for example
if I was
to
I'm trying to think I'm trying to think
there's so many things
okay so like making a cheese foam right
if you wanted to make a cheese foam you
it's really really basic you need two
ingredients and you need a whipped cream
canister and that's it but most people
don't realize that so if I were to show
some of this technique where I'm like
yeah you just take cheese you grate it
you put it in a blender you pour a
boiling cream over it you blend it until
it's smooth pour it into that whipped
cream canister and fill it with one
nitrogen cartridge shake it and you have
like a gorgeous voluminous fine dining
cheese foam something that you would see
in a restaurant and be like wow this is
amazing where I'm giving little little
techniques like that that you can't just
Google that and find it that's
interesting and how did you come up with
the concept of but better
when you started recreating other
menu items and doing it better or
cheaper
so
a lot of a lot of my content comes from
me being annoyed I feel like
the Popeye's Chicken Sandwich do y'all
remember that yeah remember that came
out yes everyone was freaking out people
were really freaking out people work
with a lot fighting each other that's
the line down the block for Popeye's
Chicken I just wanna I just want to come
on record to say uh that Popeyes where
there was a fight
I was living there it was ten five five
ten minutes away what happened with the
man the person that passed away no oh no
no no no no no no no yeah because it got
it got that bad I like how we have to
clarify what what story
there's more than one uh gosh it was
there was like two two or three fights
but uh no it was like something had
happened with like the the manage their
employees were like quitting or
something because of all the chaoticness
and uh it was actually like a a fight
between like a manager and a customer
they just started like beating the guy
up and so I was yeah I was living like
five minutes away and I was like gosh
put the town on the map over here so wow
thanks Popeyes if you want to try it
more with them yeah because you hear
about that seriously like I want to try
that is it that good see that's so
interesting to me it's like oh my God
somebody died over this time there was a
there was a mini Riot because they ran
out and people started like going crazy
I thought that was the Popeye's Chicken
Sandwich yeah I think it was Popeyes
that's insane over a chicken sandwich
that's not right I think it was 2017
that was the the chicken sandwich craze
because KFC was like wait somebody's
fighting for your chicken I want someone
to fight for my chicken
um I don't know but that that's what
annoyed me though and then I heard about
someone
I heard about someone getting killed
over this thing and I was like I was
like that's where that's where you got
to draw the line like if you're not
drawing the lineup fist fights in line
you're Drawing the Line in human life
because that is unbelievably ridiculous
and so I I just was so annoyed and so
upset at this and my immediate response
was like
uh you know what I have to go try this
because if people are losing their minds
over it it better be [ __ ] good so I
go I drive there I pull up and I was I
was doing videos at the time yeah
um I pull up I ordered the sandwich
unbelievable line it took an hour
so I'm like exhausted at this point I
get the sandwich and I take one bite and
my immediate response was
this is probably one of the worst
chicken sandwiches I've ever eaten in my
[ __ ] life the fact that I wasted my
time here and someone died over this I
can't think of a bigger waist and so
I took that energy and I was like I
could make this way [ __ ] better
easily at home with minimal equipment
this isn't this is like basic ass [ __ ]
and so I was like you know what I'll
make a video about it and I kind of had
that energy going into it too that sort
of like I'm annoyed at this the fact
that this happened and so I brought that
into the video and I was like we're
making this better you can do this at
home you not not me not just me you if
you're watching this I promise you you
can make this if you follow my
instructions it will be better and you
will have more knowledge and power and
you're gonna have fun and you're not
gonna wait in line while you watch
Jeffrey punch some dude in the face
because his chicken sandwich didn't get
there on time and so I did it and that
video immediately went pretty crazy like
day one there was an article about it
really yeah because it was at the height
of the CH of the Popeyes thing so it
immediately kind of swept up
and um there were a ton of comments of
people being like man Josh you should
make this into a series like I just
found you blah blah blah like this would
be a lot of fun to watch and so I was
like okay and here we are 70 or 80
episodes later wow now back when you
made that video were you doing YouTube
full-time or was this just a side thing
that you were working on still I think I
had just just become full-time on it I
just like
nobody's working for me at the time I've
just barely become full-time what was
that process like how long did it take
you to quit your job and and were you
nervous about quitting your job at the
time to do YouTube yeah it was it was
hard I cried when I quit my job because
you have like these attachments to these
restaurants it's not about what you get
paid it's about how much you care about
what you're doing nobody works in a
restaurant to make money unless you want
to build and you know be an owner of a
restaurant that's a different concept
but
as a line cook prep cook it's pure
passion the number of times I've seen
people go in after work
and you don't get to clock in to test
stuff and work on dish ideas for free is
staggering so I had a big attachment to
the restaurant the process of quitting
was like I it took me I think
I was ready to quit for a while it took
me three months to actually pull the
trigger and leave because I didn't want
to like let my chefs down and like make
them think you'll live me or I didn't
want to lose the relationships I had and
I didn't want to get detached from
restaurants that was like a big thing
for me and I'm still very close with
them I'm also working on my first
um and so it's like one of those things
where
yeah I was just it was just a tough
process I was making enough I I knew it
was time to leave when
I was looking at my paycheck and I was
looking at the YouTube check and the
YouTube check was probably
100x that really yeah can you share how
big the YouTube paycheck was back then
yeah so
I'm trying to remember what it was
100 100x may not may not be an accurate
maybe more like 50x but it was like I
was getting paid like around like 30 000
a month
and as a line cook getting paid 11 an
hour yeah
crazy to me like I would have seen 30
000 a month and then 11 an hour and be
like okay easy decision right there it
was it was scary because uh I was so
used to like barely being able to pay
rent for so long that seeing that kind
of money I was just I saved every dollar
I was not [ __ ] with that money at all
so it was it was tough to kind of like
step away but I will say that I knew I
wanted to leave and I knew I could
handle it it was just like I said the
emotional attachment but imagine like
line cooking and have maybe you have a
bad day because this happened several
occasions on several occasions I have a
bad day and I'm like it's just a rough
night and I'm cooking and you know maybe
maybe one of the chefs is getting on me
and by the way all these guys are
amazing so I'm not [ __ ] on them at
all but maybe you know it gets it gets
heated in the kitchen sometimes and
they're like you know maybe [ __ ] I
mean they're like God damn Josh like you
really are not on your game tonight like
you [ __ ] up two steaks did this you
did this
and they're like and they're like you
know you want that holiday bonus start
working and I'm like you have no [ __ ]
idea like you have no idea in two months
like you know not not to be a dick but
it's like in my mind what was the what
would the bonus have been
like at the time is it like 500 bucks a
thousand dollars oh like 150 or 200
bucks maybe wow
yeah now did they know you had the
YouTube channel at the time or no they
did okay but they didn't know you how
much you're making they had no idea yeah
yeah and what was your production
schedule like at that point or how many
how many videos are you posting a week
uh one to two some weeks were one it was
pretty sporadic I didn't really have a
very good posting schedule
um but I was very consistent if I had
posted one it was on Wednesdays if I
posted two it was on Sundays and
Wednesdays every single time no matter
what no you did everything yourself from
filming to planning to yep it's
fantastic yeah it was it that well
that's why I said I slept five hours
every night yeah because I literally
would sometimes I didn't sleep at all I
would film something in the morning and
I'd have like three hours before I
needed to be at work so I'd film
something in the morning or if it flip
if I was working in the morning vice
versa I would film it just before the
sun went down right I run home and get
it filmed or on a day off I would film
two videos and then I would edit
throughout the work days so like if I
had work
in the more uh in at night you know like
night shift then I would wake up at
probably 5 a.m or 4 a.m go to the gym
immediately come back at it for an hour
go to work come back at around one in
the morning and then I would edit from
one in the morning to three in the
morning and then go to bed and then wake
up at you know four or five sometimes
yeah and then how did that schedule
change when you went full time
that was wild what was your first day
like
am I waking up and there's nothing to do
but YouTube yeah I mean I remember
my media that was like I'm not going to
go and like rest I don't want to start
this off with I didn't want to start
developing bad habits so my immediate
response was like I'm working every
single day I'm working more than how
whatever the energy was that it took to
work at a restaurant I'm just gonna do
that 2x for this so I immediately
started working like way more
um I but I did get more sleep so that
was good and how was balancing a
relationship at the same time as getting
like three hours of sleep a night that
was tough I've never she also was a
teacher uh her name's Kate yeah uh yeah
she was working as a teacher so we never
saw each other for a year for an entire
year ages we lived together yeah I mean
we like so she would she would
I would wake up she would be asleep
I would come back she would be asleep
every day
except for the days off you know if
there was a day off I would see her and
we would spend a lot of time how long
have you been dating her at that time
two years I think
yeah so the year before that we saw each
other more and a year before that yeah
yeah wow I used to drive so she lived in
San Marcos at the time going to college
so I would drive from Austin which is
about a 45 30 to 45 minute drive I would
sometimes go to work immediately get off
she was in college
at you know so her hour her hours were
pretty flexed so she would stay up so I
would leave the restaurant you know
maybe midnight drive 45 minutes straight
from the restaurant all my [ __ ] with my
knives and [ __ ] drive all the way to her
in San Marcos take a quick shower and
then we would hang out from you know
like midnight or 12 30 in that case to
like two or three in the morning I'd
spend the night there and then I'd
immediately get up at like six or seven
well no that was a night show so I'll
get up close to like 10. um get ready
leave and drive all the way back to
Austin with all my knives and stuff you
know what that's absolutely crazy
because I have a very similar story when
I first uh was dating my wife
um she was going to school in Milwaukee
and I was living in Illinois which is
like an hour and a half I would wake up
again 5 30 to get the commute
um and I probably wouldn't leave until
midnight I wouldn't get there till 1 in
the morning and we would spend time so I
know exactly what you mean yeah and that
that's a tough situation to be in was
she understanding of that like right
from the gecko or or because cause I
know sometimes it's hard for your
partner to visualize like okay how long
is this going to be or did she know like
all right you're gonna grind it out for
however like were you clear up front
about like what your plan was or or how
did you feel about that not at all
I was well first off let me let me
rephrase that she was extremely
understanding I was not clear at all I
never said anything about how long it
was gonna last what it was going to look
like
um I just was expressing her how much I
liked her and I think that she saw the
effort because like I I very rarely
asked her to come to me it was like I'll
go to you you do your thing like you're
in college like let me come to you I'll
I'll do that so I think she saw the
effort and kind of like use that as I
guess
uh collateral for the emotional
attachment right where it's like okay
well he's putting in at least this much
effort in so I know he cares
um she's easy to please you know she's a
laid back out she had to deal with a lot
for me starting on because it's like
never see me
it's always late at night I'm usually
like [ __ ] dead when I saw her yeah
like dead I mean I can muster up you
know we watch a little fun movie we
laugh you know you muster up the energy
but she always got me at 50 for probably
five years yeah did that ever worry you
that that would have a toll in the
relationship
yeah yeah I mean it did but you know
what it I think it actually helped the
relationship because it made us work
through our issues more quickly because
they were exacerbated by the exhaustion
yeah but we ended up I feel like
building a really good foundation
because of it it started off poorly and
then got better and better and better
and better rather than worse whereas
most relationships start off great and
get worse and worse and worse and worse
was that like cheesy saying if you can't
tolerate me at my worst you don't
deserve me at my best don't don't ever
see it this guy no I knew this was gonna
happen I'm just saying it replies it
makes sense you know it does it does
make sense I agree with that yeah no I
agree with that I think that that
uh For Better or Worse whatever the
saying is I agree with that I also think
at the end of the day you have to be
able to do your [ __ ] like if you're
gonna be in a relationship with somebody
if you have a desire in your life or
there's something you want to do you
have to be able to do your [ __ ] and if
that person's not gonna let you do it
I'm sorry but no you need to move on
yeah you know and so my and I I felt
that way but she also had zero ego in it
so I was just like hell yeah this is
great you think distance is ever a
viable reason to break up with someone
or do you think like if you really love
that person that you can make it work so
it wouldn't work anyways basically man
distance is really hard I've done it
before I don't like it I don't think I
would want to put up with it but
but if it was with my fiance now I
definitely would but it but that's the
thing though it it skews your ability to
unto to have foresight for the future of
that relationship like now obviously in
hindsight I'm like Oh my God look at
this amazing relationship we've
developed but that took years so maybe
if it was early on in the first year how
would I have known right but
um I would say shortening of the story
is it's probably possible but it's a lot
harder what do you think Graham uh I
think everyone has different emotional
needs and if that's not something
they're comfortable with I don't think
there's anything wrong with that but you
I think it would make it easier knowing
there's an end date like hey if you
could put up with like this one year
like just go through this one year or
like a year and a half however long it
is then you at least see the end of the
tunnel but just having this indefinite
date in the future that could be any
time I think that would that'd be
difficult I I have a hot take here but I
think it's hard for somebody to see how
compatible they are if you don't live
together and I think that's changing
with like the current generation where a
lot of people are moving in before they
get married uh but like I want to know
that person's like bad habit so
everything before I like make that
decision so what was the thing that was
most surprising about calcium
this is gonna get clipped all over Tick
Tock of course all right
um
give me a second tag Kelsey in this yeah
what's her at if you can let everyone
know
didn't see
oh I think the most surprising this is
gonna show you know what this is a
fitting podcast to disclose this but uh
the most shocking thing was that this
girl really can't cook like anything at
all like like not to not just because
this is you know about food but like
um when she was living in college like I
I would like I'm not a cook myself like
I can cook but I wouldn't say I'm great
uh but I can make food
um and I would be like so like you're
saying you can't cook like how are you
eating she'd be like well like I go
visit my mom like once a month and she
makes all these like home-cooked meals
and she freezes them all and like then
she like unfreezes them and she goes and
I'm just like
like she did not know like it was so bad
I'm sorry Kelsey it was so bad she
didn't know how to make like scrambled
eggs and oh boy and so we had a bad case
and when I did a house tour video I like
made a joke about like not her not being
able to cook and uh
I I think her
you know her mom or whatever might have
taken a little bit of fence to that but
I was like I don't you know I was like
no it's not your fault like a lot of
people nowadays like you know like they
can't cook but that was the biggest
shock so yeah so starting the
relationship I had to cook I had to cook
everything basically and I and I and I
cooked everything
pretty much up until today she's still
kind of she's getting better but yeah
that was the biggest shock for me wait
I'm a little lost on what you were
talking about the biggest shock was that
she couldn't cook yes like even basic
things yeah it was because think about
it if you date somebody and you don't
move in with them you may not know that
because you know when somebody says they
don't know how to cook you assume like
oh like like yeah oh yeah yeah or like
like no but like genuinely like my wife
did not know how to cook but what's your
uh how do you do dinner well I typically
cook everything but now now she's
getting better so uh the other day she
what did she cook uh here's gosh coffee
I'm so sorry Kelsey I'm sorry for
exposes like a typical if I'm work I
work a lot and so if I'm working like a
typical thing like she'll eat is like
she likes to take like a bag of like
frozen corn from the freezer and like
she won't even heat it up she'll just
eat it
or like she'll open up like a green bean
can and she'll just like eat it out of
the can no
no no so anyway what's your name Kelsey
Kelsey you don't have to do this I'm
here for you
tell her what she can do with some
frozen corn yeah yeah give us a frozen
corn with that literally anything what
do you recommend if someone doesn't know
how to cook how can they make themselves
a nutritious meal for cheap it's not
microwaved what oh my God yes
um okay oh God I mean there's a million
things let's start they gotta start
somewhere maybe you start with scrambled
eggs you know that's that's the first
concern I had when you said that let me
start there
um the internet is is the resource I
think right and I'm not even doing this
to plug my own channel but
it's just kind of like everything's out
there Google your exact issue and find
it it's there there's a way to do it
that being said though there are there's
two tent poles that a lot of people
struggle with with cooking first one is
failure
and that's like number one people are
afraid to make something and [ __ ] it up
they don't want to dedicate their time
and money and [ __ ] it up and be bad that
makes sense it's also a larger statement
about Society but we'll talk about that
later and then the second issue is that
they don't think that they're capable
like they just think that they are okay
that it's totally separate from the
failure aspect they just think that
they're completely incapable and then
that that's for somebody else too that's
not for me I don't like do that and so
those two things kind of have to get
taken away and then you just have to
Google something and find something and
you'd be surprised because we're the
only animal on planet Earth that cooks
our food before we eat it there's no
other animal on earth known in existence
as far as I know they cook their food
before they eat it it's built in our DNA
food is more nutritious and easy to
assimilate nutrients
when you cook it so it's we're supposed
to which means that yes even your wife
can cook but I also understand that
people don't want to cook I don't want
the last thing I will say is I don't
think anyone needs to cook if someone's
like I don't want to cook cool
I don't have any uh quarrel or judgment
on that whatsoever so see I'm worried
about the time commitment of cooking
because I see this as like some women
with financial advice here I'm going to
be scared how many hours does it cost me
to cook what's the opportunity cost of
microwaving that meal I could be making
a video instead of investing instead
could be doing so many let me Google my
net worth really quickly
um divide that yeah divide that carry
the four yeah so that'd be like going to
Nobu 30 times
um but you know I get that that makes
sense but I see like I'm spending an
hour cooking something and then five
minutes eating it like the ratio is not
there like an hour for five minutes
Cooks everything for you no no let me
give you an example no no I have an
example right here of uh one of Graham's
meals and he actually made a video about
it which uh you guys can see so Josh I
want you to review this video or this
meal and I want you to tell me what
Graham could have done better okay oh my
God and this is another video old video
if you guys want to look it up it's
called how to make 97 Cent breakfast my
morning routine so what he does is he
takes eggs and he puts him in no pan
and then he is there any is there any
oil or butter in the pan before uh a
little oil I do a little like olive oil
okay I just don't want it to stick
you're adding anything you adding any uh
seasoning to the egg Ramen or nothing
just nothing what no why I don't like it
no no Graham really we I know we just
met there's no way you do not like salt
pepper yeah I like the most plain stuff
there's no can you do you have anything
to say about this I need somebody I'm
surprised I'm just as surprised as you
are I'm I thought you probably would
have salted it you've never heard him
you've never seen me use salt and pepper
I'm just saying I I would have thought
that yeah but you go out to the
restaurants yeah you go out to
restaurants and you like the food so my
guess is you think you don't like salt
and pepper because it takes more time to
go grab it and put it in your food but
if you like food from restaurants like
they season their food properly so as a
judge here
and I never had an issue with it but
it's not like having an issue it's like
okay this would make it okay hold on
let's move on here real quick I'll
finish this off real quick just so we
could get a full review and and finish
off so he takes the eggs he puts it in
the pan No seasoning whatsoever
um then he's basically making like an
omelet and he's putting a pre-shredded
sharp cheddar cheese from Kroger on
there and some turkey pre-sliced turkey
breast from Kroger also and then uh
toasting a bagel and adding
cream cheese onto the bagel so what
would you say to that meal how could we
make it better we need it we need to
make yes 97. for that meal well maybe
not with inflation now with inflation
it's yeah it's like 40 now right yeah
that makes sense
um well yeah
um I mean the meal itself in essence
there's nothing wrong with
I mean Deli me and I understand why you
use that for the price point so that
makes sense it could still be good maybe
like I don't know I would like ham
better because turkey tastes weird in
when it gets heated for some reason
unless it's in a sandwich
um
I think you just put salt and pepper
that's the one that's it that's it maybe
if there's anything I mean maybe not an
omelette but in some things yes if
there's one thing that I think people
make the biggest mistake and the first
thing I judge a restaurant on within the
it takes me a fraction of a second to
tell whether restaurants on their [ __ ]
and it is
sultan it is salt levels most places I
would say salt is single-handedly one of
the most powerful influential elements
to making great food because most places
just don't know how to put enough but I
also think that like you know in your
case some people are either sensitive to
it or it's not something that they
really
think about and it doesn't really affect
their experience but I would say most
people though their their experience is
severely affected with lack of salt but
too much could completely ruin the meal
yeah yeah I mean too much of anything
right like all right you know um it's
sort of like you want to balance the
amount of salt in it you want to
basically you want to push salt as far
as it can physically go before reaching
that salty level so if you ever go to a
restaurant you're like man this is my
favorite restaurant everything they make
is so so so so so so good those places
oftentimes are seasoning their food to
the absolute Max just before that line
one of the chefs I used to work for he
would test his sauces he would make the
sauce season it and it would take him
like 15 minutes to season a sauce he
would like season it stir taste season
stir taste like over and over and over
and the way he would uh to make sure it
had enough salt is he would take about a
teaspoon and then put a really tiny
sprinkle of salt on it right and if that
tiny sprinkle of salt took it overboard
it was there
that's really interesting that is yeah
I imagine you have a really good blood
pressure
me because of your lack of salt
conception it's low I have low blood
pressure consume more salt then right
you think so is that the movement I am
not a medical professional do not take
any of my advice yeah no mine is
consistently at the point where if it
were any lower it would be a concern
I've never heard of low blood neither
have I this guy's never stressed out
doesn't he he's constantly stressed out
but my blood pressure doesn't
doesn't go up like even when I did the
boxing thing they did the blood pressure
and it was like slightly too low and
they're like we need to do jumping jacks
and I'm like I am nervous on the inside
I'm like okay and I got it up but
consistently it's just been low wow so
you've been having some problems getting
it up yeah I'll tell you one thing my
blood pressure my blood pressure is
always high whenever I wanted to get
Twitter yeah every time I see his
Twitter he's like the housing market is
crashing and I'm like cool that's
awesome I'm really glad that I bought
two [ __ ] houses
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah so tell us
about you you bought uh you bought two
houses yes so
um one in Austin and one in La two
Studios basically because we go to La so
frequently
um and so my mentality we are actually
building a studio separately in Austin
now but the reason why we did the place
in LA
which you know is you know maybe we'll
rent it out every once in a while to pay
the mortgage whatever I'm not really I'm
flexible on it but we go there so often
and it is so expensive to bring my team
rent out of space shoot in it and I like
La I'm from La so you know I want to
spend a lot of time there
um that was actually I did the math and
I was like well if I can find that house
for this price and I build the kitchen
in it it would be less expensive and I
could rent it out to tenants and pay it
when I'm not there and or sorry rent it
out on Airbnb and you know pay for the
mortgage when I'm not there and then
when I'm there just you know don't block
those dates out so we did that and I got
a place in La and um we're not there
very often but
in the sense of like our total shoots
but we're there often enough that it's
utilized to the potential that I wanted
it for yeah what's your team look like
now
so we've got 11 dedicated people no and
then we have
um a bunch of like Freelancers that we
use
um you know thumbnail editors uh have
you guys seen this by the way have you
seen this like huge weight I'll talk
about it later uh no let's talk about it
now I'm curious now this huge wave of
like thumbnail artists yeah yeah it's
like going crazy because of Mr Beast
obviously King Legend makes sense I get
it
um but we started working with some of
them and they're cool so we use we use
some thumbnail artists
um and then my 11 dedicated people so we
have my director and who I now call my
vice president he's been with me since
almost like day one like when I was
making enough money to hire somebody he
was my first hire
um his name is Vikram he's incredible
he's extremely good work ethic top tier
what does he do so he does he does now
pretty much everything with me so like
we ideate content together he does
editing still
um I really need to get him off editing
because it's just taking too much of his
time but you know like when you care
about what you do he has like a iron
grip on some of the creative and so yeah
he still wants to edit it despite us
having several editors but so he does
directing on set
um we'll work on building out run of
shows for shoots
um he will like I said we come with
creative ideas I bounce ideas off him
sometimes we'll work on like new Revenue
sources together
um he'll handle like brand deal stuff
like creative like submitting creative
stuff between Brands and sponsorships so
that we can like make that system
efficient yeah and then everything in
between that you would imagine the only
thing he doesn't handle is like
obviously like financials like I I still
do that but um but yeah he he also
functions like a managing factor in the
team
and then we have uh we have my lead
editor Maya she's great um incredibly
talented again work ethic top tier so
she does basically oversees all edits
and helps make sure that the editing
schedule is like
consistent every single time she and she
rules it with a iron fist she's like
when's this coming when is that coming
you know she's great and then we have
you know our our other editors
um a few staff editors we have some
people who are part-time
um editing and part-time on-set shooting
so we'll have like you know one guy uh
his name is Kendrick he is on camera
when we're shooting but he's also
editing when we when he's not on Set uh
then I have my executive assistant who
basically handles like scheduling for
myself and then other people in the team
um and then we have our content
coordinator who makes thumbnails he
works on content SEO with me and
um all sorts of other things website we
built out this really cool website that
is super messed up with the recipes I
gotta figure that out but um yeah and
that's pretty much I mean there's other
people obviously but it's like editors
coordinators assistant director and some
writers that's a huge team if I don't I
don't know why I thought it was just
like you and maybe two people that's how
it feels yeah I mean you know we could
we could go lighter
oh there's two other people I completely
forgot about uh culinary as well so I
have a culinary produce I call them
culinary producer uh and then a culinary
assistant so they both like measure
ingredients out if stuff needs to be
pre-prep they pre-prep it the day before
I'll send them the recipe that's a great
idea yeah so I'll send them the recipe
and all this stuff and I'm like hey
um you know be sure to get these
ingredients and this is exactly how we
need to prep this out make this sauce
make this soup boil this down do this
this bring it all the way up to where it
needs to be so that when we get on set
it's a three-hour shoot not an eight
hour shoot
um and they do all that that stuff uh
and help with uh cleanup yeah like I've
seen it with some of the cooking
channels where they put something in an
oven and then there's an oven next to it
they're like and then they just
immediately take it out hooked yeah that
I mean that's how you do it otherwise it
takes so long if you're doing everything
uh in French terms would be El minut
which means like everything to order
everything right away oh the chicken
here's the chicken it's done
um it's way better if it's pre-made so
we'll have like sauces that take six
hours to boil down right so we're gonna
do all that the day before put in a
quart container leave it in the fridge
so that when we start the shoot we're
boiling the sauce down and then you know
it's boiling on camera we get the shot
okay cool I go put it off to the side
and then I pull out the one that's
already done like looks like this wow so
but we do that with with those people so
they'll they'll be pre-prepping that for
me and I'll go check on and make sure
that it's right and all that what's your
schedule look like day to day
chaos yeah yeah you it sounds like it's
really organized right now it's very
chaotic but
I like working a lot you know even if we
had enough employees for me to have more
time for myself I would not do that you
know it's just it's I like the process
I'm sure you guys as well you know we
all work a lot here
um it's doing the stuff that's fun
so my schedule is usually
I get up at
four or five every day no matter what
weekend holiday doesn't matter I do not
get up later than that unless a special
occasion like I gotta I stayed up way
too late the night before or something
else right maybe a vacation which I have
taken one vacation in the last 10 years
so so I get up at four or five in the
morning go to the gym come back
once I get back I immediately am like on
emails or I'm working on writing recipes
I'm writing stuff for my next book I'm
writing stuff for some other Concepts
that I'm working on Restaurant related
stuff that I'm working on
um and then buy about nine this is
non-filming days yeah um by about like
nine it's like back-to-back calls from
nine to five p.m and then I'll try to
like squeeze stuff in between that like
write a recipe in between calls
um and then I'll test recipes at night
if I can
um I would say I test Maybe
10 of our recipes before we shoot them
so I just like write the recipe and it
usually works and that's that and then
shooting days same thing but there's a
shoot in the middle of the day that
lasts about six hours so you take calls
for like eight hours sometimes yeah
what do you what do you have to talk
about that so
I was kind of thinking the same thing
like what's saying you know I just want
to say this I I don't remember I don't I
hate them to mix it too but it was
either Alex formosi I don't know if
you're familiar with him or Elon Musk
maybe I think it was Elon Musk one of
the two said like
oh the meetings it was like 95 of
meetings aren't needed yeah also if a
meeting has more than like three people
in it like everyone that isn't talking
or like listening or whatever or
directly related to that meeting is just
wasting their it was Elon it's just
wasted yeah yeah it was Elon and it's
really made me re-evaluate like
obviously like calls are important but a
lot of the times like a call can be
solved just with like a simple text or
like a group call could just be like a
group text like it's just a lot more
efficient yeah well it's funny you say
that we're actually working on grinding
that down a little bit for that exact
reason because there are some calls that
are inefficient that we have regularly
because I like to be I'm a communicative
guy so I like to communicate with
everyone as much as possible but I agree
with that and there are calls we're
taking off that being said though
um it's mostly because we condense a lot
of my calls throughout the week on like
just a couple of days because all my
other days I'm too busy to take calls
like you know filming and stuff yeah
filming or recipe developing or just
we're working on a lot of projects at
once so you know
we're building the studio in Austin so
like there might I need to get on the
phone call with on a phone with my
contractor right I need to get on the
phone with the guy that we're leasing
the building with I need to get on a you
know so like little things like that
we're just I think it's a combination of
working on so many projects and some
calls being inefficient that we're
working on grinding those down and then
the third thing is we squish it all on
the light just Monday and Tuesday and
then Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday I almost never have calls
interesting yeah how's your business
broken down now in terms of the income
is it is it ad revenues sponsorships
your own products so it's broken down
into a couple different sectors
obviously we have ad revenue from
YouTube
um and then we have like you know all
the other things like Snapchat and all
the other social media sites that
produce income
um and then there's my cookbook my
second cookbook my
merchandising and then we are working on
some other stuff uh I really like to
take my time with the product space yeah
you know I really don't like the idea of
being like well I can make I can make a
million dollars right now I just come up
with this project and and white label it
a call today like quality is so
important to me I want people to buy
stuff that they love so we're working on
that
um product space obviously brand
sponsorships
um and then sometimes I'll do like a
little bit of like Consulting work but
that's pretty infrequent so I wouldn't
even really calculate that in
um
and I'm probably forgetting some other
things but that's some of it can I break
it down like a pie like for example this
is this certain yes or whatever so
there's
adrev is probably anywhere from 30 to 50
percent
book is anywhere from 20 to 30 percent
probably closer to 50 45 for ad rev
um and then everything else kind of
breaks down pretty evenly sure I would
say yeah
um have you ever thought about doing the
Mr Beast approach of doing like the the
Mr Beast Burger but you could come up
with your own concept and and have a
ghost kitchen do it for you so I've
looked into ghost kitchens a bunch I
knew about ghost kitchens before Mr
Beast probably ever even thought about
it because I was working in I knew about
ghost kitchens when they were just
beginning to like become a thing who
knows maybe Mr Beast knew I'm not like
trying to say anything but
um it is so hard to maintain good
consistency of product in a ghost
kitchen so I would like to do one to get
food to more people that being said from
a professional professional's
perspective working in food I'd rather
have a brick and mortar and it I'd
rather put my energy towards that for
now and do
a ghost kitchen later we were approached
by the same company that approached Mr
Beast at the same time he got approached
and they were like we can open 100
locations for you in the next six months
and I was like wow that sounds [ __ ]
horrible that's not good because if you
do that there's going to be crazy
inconsistency you're gonna have so much
[ __ ] so many [ __ ] up orders and guess
what
Mr Beast had a lot of [ __ ] up orders
they had to go back and fix a lot of
things I remember talking to read about
it and I was like man I'm I'm so sorry
like if I can help you guys please let
me know they managed they did it I felt
so bad because I was looking on Twitter
and I I think the first night that they
came out with it I placed an order and I
was looking at Twitter because I was so
curious I wanted to make a whole video
on this yeah but ever it's already
saturated yeah yeah but um but yeah I've
seen some of the inconsistencies on that
and just how they've had to deal with
that thankfully it seems like everyone
was super understanding it was like hey
you can't just do this and have every
Order Perfect like it's gonna happen so
it seems like and and they made it right
so quickly they're like if anything is
wrong we'll send you another one we'll
give you it free we'll give you a you
know a gift card on top of that like
that I have to say when it first came
out I placed an order for me and a bunch
of friends and uh it was like probably
eighty dollars worth of food or
something and I got half of it could not
figure out a way to submit a claim to
get a refund like it and and there was
problems with this because it like Mr
Beast had put out a thing like if this
happened to you like tweet out at me and
I was like yeah I was about to say you
just tweet out I was like I'm not gonna
tweet at him so Mr Beast if you're
watching this like I'm gonna put my
venmo right here you want to send me 40
bucks get over it Alex come on listen
I'm I'm a hard-working man you know
forty dollars is forty dollars I will
say this I will say this they did an
extremely good job I have so much
respect for them in the way that they
handled that I agree they did so good
um I love them both and read I don't
know where Reed came into play there but
read like was very on top of it with him
so I was surprised to see how much they
cared about the product which you don't
see very often so they did a really good
job turning that around but let's let
just to refocus back on to if I did that
yeah that is Imagine like my whole brand
is centered around my food being good
how the [ __ ] would that go if I did that
happen to me all right wow yeah that
would have [ __ ] destroy me for Jimmy
it's he's not known as the oh now he
almost is with feastables but
he's figured it out like the thing is
like he from a qual he cares about
quality I know he does but they've
figured out they figured out how to fix
the pipeline so they're good but like I
would have been a guinea pig in that
scenario and like I care so much about
the experience of the person eating my
food I could never risk that could no
not even one meal you know I mean I used
to work in restaurants where every
single plate counted every single plate
so imagine like I'm just like okay let
me open a hundred places like let's see
what happens like God bless hope this
works out you know and yeah I would that
would have been I would have been in
like shambles if that happened to me but
you built a substantial business off the
cookbook yeah that is it does seem like
crazy numbers yeah we didn't expect it
to do as well as it did which I was
surprised about
um I not to say that I didn't think it
would do well
I'll give you an example of why I so I
told you I released a cookbook when I
was 17 right it didn't sell I think it
sold like 10 000 copies which is like
pretty cool for a kid right but
um I I went to you know the San
Francisco Ferry Building
do you know what you've never been how
is that possible how's it possible I
don't know you guys have never heard of
the San Francisco have you heard of the
San Francisco never nope
have you been to San Francisco yeah I
have I like whoever is listening to this
I know that there are people listing
this podcast that is like wow this just
changed their opinion about it
[Laughter]
yeah yeah they're warfing it up over
there right um so short on the story
it's a really big beautiful building in
San Francisco that has a bookstore in it
that's really famous and a bunch of
other like little shops to serve food
it's very big it's like uh
if you saw it it's a very grandiose like
long long building and uh so I went
there when I was a kid with my buck to
do a book tour at the time this was when
I was like 17 years old and uh one
person showed up to the book tour and
which was awesome like I was so scared
it still feels good but it's also kind
of bummed out where I was just like I
don't know why I expected more people
when I and again I was 17 so you know
those kinds of things get to you and it
stuck with me like it stuck with me uh
fast forward to me launching this book
you know I was 25 when it came out so I
launched this book and when I got to the
ferry building I was filled with fear
because I was like I was like what if
that all happens again like I don't know
if I can handle that right now after all
the work that I put into this book like
I put a lot into this book I don't know
if I can handle walking up to this and
only seeing like two or three people or
even like 50 people like I not to say
that I needed a lot of people there to
make me feel good but I was just like it
was like a defining moment of like this
is how it's gonna go and I didn't see
anyone in the bookstore and I was like
[ __ ] like it's there's nobody here
there's no way and um one of the ladies
came out who was there when I came there
the first time she's like it's nice to
see you again I was like oh yeah and
she's like they're outside and I walked
outside and there were 2 000 people
knocked around the building No 3 000
people 3 000 people wrapped around the
building
and I'd never seen a line like that
before like literally the line went down
the entire length of this football sized
building all the way around it and I was
like holy [ __ ]
that's when I realized I think the
book's doing good and um every time we
did a book event it was literally like 3
000 people showed up every single time
we did a book event in Chinatown in LA
and we did released a special burger and
I was like we'll do a book signing come
get a burger it'll be fun
um and the line was all wrapped around
Chinatown and I was like oh
so people are liking the book that's
great
um and uh you know then then the news
had come out I remember when I was
waiting to find out if we hit New York
Times bestseller and I was sitting at
the computer waiting for the email like
refreshing they're like oh we find out
today and I'm refreshing and I'm like
you know what like I had two two
positions in my mind I was like if we
don't get any New York Times bestseller
that's totally cool but the other side I
was like I have something in mind that I
want to go and get if we hit New York
Times bestsell with just any position
just give me just one position and then
I got a phone call from my publisher and
the publisher and they said that we got
number one New York Times bestseller on
in all genres oh my God and I was like
for all genres like outside of cookbooks
and they're like all genres so we
outsold every single book
um how did you get that time period
for uh I think it was almost it was we
were one of the like top
selling books of the year I think in all
genres how did you do that was that just
the YouTube channel
it was a
you know I'd love to say that there was
a I mean there was a strategy I mean why
would I launch a book with no strategy
but I mean it wasn't an exorbitant you
know chock full of do this that then and
this and then I mean we promoted it on
the channel and we did some fun skits
and that was kind of it you know we
promoted it a lot on the YouTube channel
and I did a I did like one tick tock on
it
[Music]
um
I tweeted it out a few times I had it in
a lot of videos like where it was in the
background so some product placement
stuff and but I mean I just spoke very
honestly about it and I was like look
you know this is a book that I want to
release for a long time blah blah blah
and it was just cool to see people show
up I think people were excited to see
that it was like a professional's book
instead of all these other you know
personalities so to speak a lot of
people in food are per there's a lot of
personalities in food that have not put
in like the in a extraordinary amount of
work that I put in
to a craft and so I think it was really
cool to see the people kind of return
the favor a little bit where they were
like it felt like
uh the age-old concept of like oh is
this real like do people even care about
this anymore it was a really nice
reassuring moment to see that they do
wow what's the process of writing a book
how do you do that it's
aren't you are you working on one gram
now
yeah you're not about that huh no I'd
much rather make a video yeah for me I
don't read that many books I'll listen
to like audiobooks but I don't read it
I've not sat down there and read a book
and so I feel like why would I do
something that you know I'm not gonna
sit down and read a book once I put up
at some point yes once I put out my
third book it will be officially I will
have written more books than I've read
all the way through
it's just I just don't read books all
the way through but
um so the process is
pretty lengthy they give you like a
deadline and and it's sort of like a
wrap like a race to get to that point
um
for a cookbook it's normally broken down
in like okay how many recipes are going
to be how many pages that book has over
100 recipes and like 200 and something
Pages
um and then you you define what recipes
are going to be there you write them and
everything and then you figure out what
the book is prior to doing that
obviously figure out what the book is
going to be about what's the concept and
then you build everything out from there
so it starts at the top of the tree and
then you build the rest of the tree out
um
it's not that bad if you really know
what you're doing and you know what
you're writing about in my opinion if
you're struggling to write a book
probably you shouldn't be writing that
book it should be easy I'm sure if you
if if I don't know if someone came to
you and offered you enough money and
they were like hey do this book
um you know maybe you do it
and they you know they ask you to talk
about something that you know the most
about you probably have a pretty easy
time writing about it it takes a long
time and it's a bit of a grind but
you know you know it's all it's all up
here it's tough for me because I feel
like well I just make a YouTube video
yeah like it would probably be with real
estate investing of some sort but I made
so many videos on that
that's fair and I feel like then the
video just gets pushed out the algorithm
helps and people could watch it they
could you know well pause it come back
to it they could listen to it in the car
I've thought about
yeah I would say it's two things think
about it like you have this podcast you
have what you're doing on YouTube and
you have what you do on Instagram etc
etc and what's smart about that is you
know you're making content for people
who want to consume it differently
and text is still a piece of content
that people want to consume differently
and there's only a few categories that
perform really well in literature and
that is food and financial
self-help and maybe a couple of you know
fiction books that somehow blow up like
you know Harry Potter is a great book
right a great series you know that blue
because of what it is that that would be
like another format for you to put out
and like if they gave you a better
royalty you know a lot of people say
books don't pay I didn't think that was
the case until this
um granted like it did it wasn't a great
split for the first book but it got
better after that oh there's a publisher
author split yeah so like they basically
do all the work like logistically and
you just have to write
well I mean I I did more than right I
was I also was the creative and art
director for the book I was we hired a
photographer but I basically chose all
the direction of the visuals for the
photography I did all the food styling I
did all the well I I
um brought on some people to help me
cook the food because it was like we
filmed in in six days we took all the
photos for the book wow 100 over 100
recipes we cooked in six days and
photographed so you do all of the
content inside the book and then the
publisher does everything aside from
that and they did they pitch you on the
idea or do you pitch them on the idea
I'll never let somebody pitch me on an
idea and it better be really good I've
never I don't like that kind of stuff
but a publisher would approach you and
say hey we want to publish a book for
you do you have any ideas you pitch them
on that yep and then they either agree
or decline to it and then yeah okay yeah
it depends on where you're at with them
right like I I think I have a really
good relationship with my publisher so I
could go to them and be like I want to
do this book and they'd probably just be
like okay cool and we would go and do it
sure um but after that
um yeah it's pretty much like you said
you make all the content they will put
it on a book and make it look nice and
they have editors that edit it for you
and they know how to do all the
traditional things that would be done
for the book so distribution printing
has to be thought of because that
shouldn't get expensive but like when I
was looking at sales and everything I
did the math and and um you know
assuming that splits are good but if I
had self-published the book
I probably would have made about
granted I would have to pay people you
know so it would be a little bit less
than this after paying a you know an
editor and for distribution and
everything but the grant the gross would
be probably about 15 million dollars on
one that's insane in the first year now
In fairness though do you think you
would have done that even hiring out
uh with that book versus the publisher
who already has those those resources
and that knowledge like is that
something proprietary to them that like
it's I feel like even if you hired it
out it wouldn't it might not be the same
quality that they're able to do right
off the bat if you don't know what
you're doing yeah it could go horribly
wrong and I don't think we would have
been able to do it because distribution
at the time this was at the height of
all of the you know shortages of this
and we don't have these materials we
don't have these materials and you know
what I'm talking about like kind of uh
back end of kovid but when there was
like nothing left they managed to
distribute and print this book while
nobody else could print their books like
everyone was struggling printing books
and my publisher
is the reason why we were able to put
out so many books I don't know I imagine
if we couldn't print books and we're
getting all these orders that would be
horrible I mean and so honestly I gotta
hand it to them like they were because
they're so big they were like reaching
to Pub we were printing the book in
Canada in the U.S in overseas and like
printing it in multiple parts of the
world and like Distributing them all
over the place in order they had to
coordinate all that I mean I don't know
that I would have been able to do that
on my own how much do you think of that
was just really good timing because
issuing that book around covid when
everyone is at home I feel like cooking
would take uh a lot more priority for a
lot of people because they're home they
have the time partially maybe it it may
have been this is actually more so on
the tail end when people were already
going back out eating and things were
getting a little more normalized
definitely not 100 but like families
were getting together again and it was
it was much better than the height of
kovid
um personally I think it was good timing
because people more people were cooking
at the time uh because people started
cooking in Covenant and then for some
people it's stuck but other than that
um maybe a little bit of good timing uh
I honestly am a big believer in brand
and being honest and being good with
your intentions and I I really am like I
care so much about what we do and I
think I've made that evident to my you
know me being real in the sense of my
craft that people just sought and they
bought because they know that I care and
I that's what I think that's why I think
it happened personally just because I
feel like I've built a really good
relationship where I'm like look this is
what it is like I don't I don't [ __ ]
around with this stuff no do you want to
open a restaurant yeah
multiple where everywhere
but
it's a process it's easier said than
done some of these restaurants are
really expensive to build you can't just
like you know nowadays to build a
restaurant you want to build a nice
restaurant and and I'm not saying it has
to be overly gaudy but you know the
restaurant I want to build
easily four or five million dollars that
much starting cost
yep wow and does that oh obviously that
would include um rent for a building it
would not include rent rent would be
anywhere but I mean rent can be really
high so are we just talking about the
build out alone for all the equipment 45
million plus you're probably looking at
another I don't know a million and a
half a year and just overhead I'm
guessing yep rent can range anywhere
from 20 000 a month to 75 000 a month uh
in Austin depending where you are
there's a buddy of mine works with a
huge Restaurant Group and they have a
restaurant in Austin that's on South
Congress or no I'm sorry not South
Congress um
and their rent is 85 000 a month
and it's not a huge building yeah that's
to me that's exorbitant that's like way
too much
I'll go for it as you say it's not worth
that much in my opinion what type of
food would you make in the restaurant
depends on which restaurant I want to
open I have multiple Concepts uh sort of
already built out with menus and
everything but I think that I want to do
uh like a finer dining concept like a
high high high fine dining and then I
think
I have another concept that I I can't
really say but it's sort of a Midway
point and very much like my style of
cooking like me incarnate
um and something I think people would
really really like and that's the one
that I'm probably going to lead with
first and then just kind of build out
from there I like the concept of Beast
Burger I think Beast Burger is really
cool I think people love hamburgers so
maybe maybe there's like a fast food
concept as well
um Smash Burger yeah I mean like Smash
Burgers are fun but it's also an
oversaturated Market there's so many
burger places now everyone's doing a
burger place
um I love the dobrix concept that's cool
so but I I you know I'll tell you right
now that
once my restaurant drops good luck to
everybody else that's starting the
restaurant really yeah I would love to
you know what would have been a uh maybe
a saucy video is dope Ricks but better
yeah well anytime someone drops a
concept my first thought is like let's
do a collab and uh we'll make it but
better but then we put that on your menu
it would do really well yeah and then do
like do that in waves yeah it's it's
yeah it's it's you would do that with
dough bricks totally if anyone here is
watching yeah it has a connection yeah
that would be a great idea yeah I think
it would do really well I think it would
do really well and it'd be a lot of fun
for people too because you know you have
your core menu and people know what
they're gonna get pepperoni this and
that and this and that but this gives
you an opportunity to try something new
on your menu
in two ways a you can stress test it do
people like it or not they'll probably
like it and B you you're providing
diversity to your com to your customer
base so they they're going to come back
and order again and again and again but
they know every once in a while they'll
get something special uh so and then
maybe down the line you're like this
sold so well I'm gonna put this on the
menu and then maybe it becomes your new
number one core menu item which would be
great and for a restaurant how often are
you supposed to change out the menu or
offer newer items many restaurants don't
change them like very often at all
sometimes never it depends on how much
how far behind you are you know if the
restaurant's really old school and you
haven't updated your menu in like 50
years you got to look at it two ways
either you need to stay that way and be
be Mr authentic traditional or you need
to honestly have changed your menu like
20 years ago change it to to match the
pace of the style so maybe every 10 15
years but it's not like a total overhaul
it's like little things here and there
you know what I would love to see you do
um I would love to see like a more
realistic version
um of like
I forgot the name of the show but it's
like that I think Gordon Ramsay was on
it where they flipped like a failing uh
restaurant and they'd like change the
menu and they do all this stuff but
maybe it's more like just the menu part
because I think you're really good with
food and me I'm sure there's businesses
out there that are struggling with the
direction of their menu but I think for
like a foodie audience that would be
really cool and it would bring people to
the to the restaurant I agree yeah yeah
I think I think that would be fun to do
there's so many Concepts that we could
do it's just my concern with that is
legal ah there's a lot of legal stuff
with that you know if something gets
messed up and then their restaurant dive
bombs not good I got a quick question do
you have to have like elevated taste
buds to be a good Chef because isn't it
true that like like some people are just
born with the ability to notice certain
flavors that other people wouldn't
notice or they're more sensitive to
certain things I think it's possible but
I don't know that I necessarily have I
mean I guess I do but it's hard I mean I
started when I was five so it's sort of
like it's trained you know it's I've
spent so much time I can eat things that
aren't that good and in my there's two
my brain is in two pieces when I'm
eating it and it's and let's say it's
bad one part of my brain is like it's
food whatever I'm just gonna eat this
and the other part of my brain is like
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] who the [ __ ] cook
this doesn't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing I hate every second of this you
know but it's like the professional and
then the human being
kind of like clashing a little bit so I
don't know I mean I do think you can
train your palate I think anyone can
train their palette and I think you can
be born with maybe a higher sensitive
sensitivity to certain flavors like
that's why certain people don't like
things like fish or cheese or you know
what I mean so I could see that I got
more questions random ones okay what do
you think about in and out from a foodie
oh top tier really loving and out one of
my favorite burger places and I I I can
tell you why so
let me just address the elephant in the
room their fries are ass okay yeah but
you can order them well done and they're
a little better
I don't go for the fries I go for the
burger first off the price is completely
unbeatable unbelievably unbeatable have
they raised their prices with inflation
or no I know it's still like 2.75 not
much though I mean they figured it out
food cost you know they figured that out
big time but it's more so the whole
experience you go to any other burger
restaurant it genuinely feels like they
sat on the [ __ ] Burger before you ate
it I mean every time it is so far away
from what you really initially desired
that it's just like why the [ __ ] did you
even go here but you go to I'm sorry
guys I have a foul mouth if it's not
evident no you're good I've just
realized I'm the only one cussing in
here I don't know if that's like a No-No
um I work I work we want the guests to
be themselves I worked in restaurant
industry my entire professional life
it's like totally screwed my vocabulary
in that sense that being said
um
so anyway the burger when you get a
burger it's just like beautiful every
time the presentation it's like
perfectly wrapped the lettuce is poking
out I mean stylistically when I look at
that I eat with my eyes before I eat so
I see that I'm like that's great I
appreciate that I feel good about eating
this they put effort in this and then
the flavor is so consistent I mean it's
just always good but I don't know maybe
it's Nostalgia so I'm gonna raise a
point of contention here I actually I
think in and out sure yes it's the best
fast food Burger yes 100 especially
value considered uh but I do think that
there can be some variance and
inconsistency with not only the flavor
but also the texture sometimes I go and
the buns are harder than other times but
I eat a ton of in and out so I have like
a lot oh this guy has like data I don't
even have yeah it's got a spreadsheet so
it's it's really good but sometimes
exactly you'd be surprised there are
times where you go and you're just a
little underwhelmed you thought you knew
what to expect and he's tracking like an
inflation chart but it's but it's based
off of uh In and Out Burgers
exactly it yeah that'd be a fun tweet
um yeah I I well you know still is great
any restaurant has inconsistency unless
it's like a three Michelin if they want
to maintain their stars but like most
restaurants have inconsistency it's just
a matter of how much that how often
that's happening I'm I've actually never
ran into it I will say half the time
I've eaten in and out I might not have
been sober yeah be fair sure at 2 am
so another question when someone says I
want to thank the chef you know did they
ever pull you out of the kitchen did
that ever happen to you where they had
to thank you most of the time
in the restaurants that I've worked at
the people are kind of afraid of you
low-key they're like afraid of
disrespecting you which is a really
weird power complex that happens in
restaurants and I know if there are any
line cooks or chefs watching this they
absolutely know what I'm talking about
where there's a certain you ever go to a
nice restaurant you're kind of like okay
let me not act stupid one
so do you know what I'm talking about
then yeah yeah I was a but it wasn't
like a nice nice restaurant it was a
good Steakhouse yeah and there's but
there's like a certain respect people
have so a lot of the time they would
thank us through the waiter waitress
they would tell their waiter waitress oh
my God this was really good can you
please tell whoever made this and so and
you always like throw a little party
whenever that happened it was amazing it
was the best feeling ever so like I
remember I'd be cooking
and make and then you know maybe it's
really crazy and then they'd go like hey
Josh
that A5 steak
they said they wanted to kiss you and
then the whole kitchen like the whole
kitchen is just like everyone's like
screaming and then
um it's like this huge that's one of the
beauties of working in a restaurant
that's why you get so attached it's like
a Brotherhood camaraderie uh and
everyone's like yeah yeah like Josh is
on fire tonight or like whoever
whoever's doing it and then um they'll
like sometimes like the other stations
will like make food for you and send it
out and get send it to your your Station
instead of a table and you'd like you
know get like a plate as like a reward
or something so yeah that's really cool
yeah it's a reminder to thank the chef
more yeah never really do have you ever
done that the way that I think so the
way that it uplifts the kitchen is
unreal really even if the kitchen's in a
bad spot or or even if the kitchen's in
a good spot doesn't matter if somebody
says if somebody takes the time to go to
the kitchen tells you know so and so hey
this was really good if it's a healthy
kitchen and by healthy I mean like good
attitudes and not toxic everyone's gonna
get so hype really
how often is it though that someone
complains or sends something back and
you know it's like this is BS it's
perfect I hate to say it I haven't
worked a lot of restaurants that's
happened a ton but it does happen most
of the time it's pretty low-key nothing
really happens every once in a while
it's really bad and they're like you
know they want something redone but
normally like honestly if they send
something back we
the restaurants I've worked for were
really smart they always were like you
don't like it no worries even if they're
being a dick we'd just be like cool what
would you like
that's free you can either eat it or
we'll toss it what would you like you
want this cool done let me just remake
it call it a day we just like
extinguished the problem immediately
never got exploited like some guy's like
oh I could just go and complain every
time I come here and get two for that
every time well coming in the next day
and the next day oh this steak sucks
again we've definitely had some stuff
like that before we'll throw them out of
the restaurant oh interesting yeah cool
yeah we'll throw them out of the
restaurant and what happens to all the
food that gets uneaten because sometimes
I see plates oh my God like oh it gets
ravaged by the people in the back does
it no okay
dude I was a busboy so like if any food
got sent back you'd know I'm you know
I'm eating good chowing down that's
nasty bro I know bro what if someone has
like has something well you know I like
what if they don't I'm tuning my immune
system so yeah I got strong smart yeah
because of that yeah I hate seeing
wasted food like I see when someone gets
up and they have half their plate and
I'm looking at that thing they could
take that home oh no matter I could take
that home he has been at a it was a
sushi restaurant right and the guy next
to you he wasn't finishing his Sushi you
went to this man at another table and
asked him for the food no way yeah Ram
it was half a dare it was many years ago
I I joked and I'm like he's not gonna
finish that because they paid already
and like half the plate was just uneaten
it was Sushi and I'm like I wonder if
he's gonna finish that like it's gonna
get thrown out and it was really good
and so a body was like you should just
ask him like really you think that's
weird he's like not his ass and I think
he was on a date too and I'm like no man
it's gonna be weird are you gonna finish
that and he looks down it's like no I
was like can I have it and he's like
sure oh my God that guy must have [ __ ]
it I bet he still tells that story today
yeah I bet he does yeah hey if you're
watching on YouTube here he is
house in Santa Monica this must have
been like
2016. so like it's not that the people
will do their magic you guys know what
to do find this man for us and he must
have been on a first date you should
take him on a date first day probably I
don't know it seemed like a first date
like they gave first aid Vibes I don't
know
his wife of 50 years or something like
that what if that started a fight she's
like you shouldn't have gave him the
food I wanted it you could have taken
that home yeah
maybe they're not together anymore
because of that yeah maybe there's so
many dominant effects that could happen
in that moment you never know when food
is sent back
I never ever wanted to eat it off the
plate so that's Wilding to me but that
being said
um yeah it's usually the waste in
restaurants is exorbitant it's
Graham if you saw
how much waste is in a restaurant it's
it's sickening
it's sickening it's really bad some
restaurants are good about it but even
the ones that try to be good at it it is
really bad why to the point where uh it
depends I mean
in fine dining uh this is something
that's not talked about a lot in fine
dining you know you want everything to
be perfect
vegetables don't come perfectly shaped
you need to cut them to be perfectly
shaped meat doesn't come perfectly
shaped and you cut it to be perfectly
shaped
which means what happens to all the trim
when you're trimming it down to get a
perfect little square on a piece of meat
what happens to all the little strips of
meat you just cut off right we try to
use it doesn't always get reused
sometimes it's not reusable it should
have a junk plate like every fine dining
well maybe not a fine dining like if you
have that one table in the junk table
well you go there you get a discounted
meal it's all the the all the shrimp I
mean it's it's funny it's a funny idea
it it wouldn't be a bet what I would do
I'm giving this [ __ ] away for free
this is what I I will be doing
so for to-go orders you have a to-go
order menu that's totally separate so
you have some of your menu items but
it's a it's a slightly different menu
just for to go orders right you had a
couple new items on there that you can't
get in-house
and then you use the trim to make some
of those things so let's say you have a
short rib dish right and you're cutting
short of all nice and it's like
sous-vide for several hours falls apart
right you take all that short road trim
you shred it up and then you press it
into a pan so it's like a flat layer you
weigh it down you cut it into little
squares or Rod or whatever shape you
want you can pan seared it's like a
crispy little like shredded Beefcake
it's nice make that a To-Go menu item
now you've used a trim you didn't throw
it away and you made money off of it you
you made a better margin on your overall
food cost and you provided value with a
new item for two orders the expectation
is a lot lower to go food it's lower but
also you can make something nice out of
it if you're creative you can make
anything out of anything if you're
creative so I think trim can be used but
most restaurants don't use it so then
when you start to add that up think
about like let's say
um you know a a trash can right the big
restaurant trash cans you know which one
I'm talking about the ones that are
[ __ ] horrible to fill with the bag
let's say six of those get rotated maybe
three to four times
in a night
filled with some garbage but a lot of
those items like trim and just stuff
that goes bad and vegetables and stuff
that falls in the ground when sauce gets
spilled which happens all the time
I mean that every day almost you know
like maybe I don't know 300 days out of
the Year even more 350 days out of the
year
for one restaurant for one restaurant
yeah so tons of trash how would you take
these experiences for your own
restaurant I mean sustainability being
ethical paying people really well
um
I mean trying to it's hard to address
them all right if it was easy to address
then all restaurants would be doing it
it is hard to do so I mean I kind of
want to go in with that kind of energy
of like trying to hit all those points
but let's talk about real quick uh
paying people well what do you think
about the whole
uh tip culture in America do you think
that we should just pay servers x amount
more and then markup prices x amount
more because it's like a a certain level
tip should be expected to be able to pay
them a certain wage or do you think that
no they're a service-based industry like
they can make more money by providing
excellent service what what's your take
on that and uh that does this doesn't
mean you would do it but what what model
do you think you would do in your your
restaurant it's really hard I don't know
what model I'm gonna do so I can't I
can't say what that is because there's
so many decisions that have to go into
it
um it's tough right because I mean it
makes sense why tips exist but I think
it sucks that that only waiters and
waitresses get the tips what about the
people that are cooking the food
normally they don't so it's tough when
you're like you know let's say uh you
know a lead line cook and you've been
working at that restaurant for three and
a half years and you get paid let's say
13 or 14 an hour
um and meanwhile you know a waiter or
waitress is making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and you're just sitting
there like like you don't even care
about what you're doing but I'm back
here and I've dedicated my entire life
to this and I'm really good at it and I
make stuff that people love that takes
so much time to create like and come up
with and like some place some dishes
take like months to come up with so I
would try to make it in a way that it's
Financial it financially behooves
everyone as much as possible but I
really don't know what it's gonna look
like until I start working on the
restaurant uh but I I can at least say
that that's something that's at top of
mind for me for sure for sure yeah I
know with sugar fish they do the no
tipping it's just it's included I don't
even know if it's a a set amount that
gets added on I think it's just built
into the menu and then you just pay and
you're done
um but I've also seen a lot about
tipping fatigue where I even went to
like some random like Supermarket sort
of place it was like one of those little
convenience stores and just checked out
yeah
buttons right here buttons right but
this was something where it's like just
scan a few items and then turn it around
it wasn't like a service or anything and
I look at that thinking like I don't
want to be that guy who's like no tip so
I put something but then I'm like is 10
insulting but then again he just turns
it around like but but that's everywhere
now and I feel like it it's it's turning
people off I I heard I think it was
valuetainment was mentioning that people
are now tipping less because of that
feature just overall I could see that
yeah it's an oil change and they asked
for a tip
I swear to God
a hand
oh we know it was a smog test it wasn't
how was your service it was a small 20
no but the thing is it was a cheap smog
test like I think it was like 50 like 20
and then when I checked out they had the
tip feature and I always whenever they
flip the thing around I'm like you know
what I'm expecting I'm gonna tip and I
always click the middle one whatever it
is so my finger a default went to the
middle I'm like stupid I'm tipping for a
smog test but sure I'll click the middle
one and I look and as my finger is
pressing it's like 72 percent
it was like 52 I think it was like 26.52
and then like 26 was like the bottom the
thing yeah but the thing is it was such
a cheap oil change I think they like
expect people to tip a bunch because it
wasn't like like the owner was the one
that was like you know that would
release or sorry smog test smog test yes
the owner of the smog place like was
checking me out so the tip would go to
him so I basically just paying more for
the smog test
I wonder if there's got to be like a tax
thing going on there like maybe tips are
done differently or maybe it's what is
it done with stripe I believe it I have
no clue maybe they process uh they get
probably a fee too on that tip so
they're making more money the more you
tip because imagine if every one of your
transactions now pays on average at 10
more yeah 10 more Revenue just for
turning that thing around yeah I could
see that yeah
that's what that's whack I always think
it's funny whenever I go to a coffee
shop and then I'm like you know what
actually I'm just gonna get like a
bottle of juice and a water and like
maybe one of the pre-packaged snacks and
then I see the tip thing and I'm like
do I tip because I just grabbed this out
of the refrigerator and then just buy it
you know what I wouldn't be bothered as
much by it if it weren't Anonymous but I
know like they see it and they turn
around and I'm always like just you know
that's exactly it and the thing is
that's another thing because you're
known as like all the millionaire guy
yeah I don't want to be like when I when
I checked out at the smog thing I I
pushed it was like 52 I think I
recognized me so it ended up working in
my favor yeah oh wow yeah my fiance and
I now like sometimes uh you know I don't
know if we like watch a movie or
something and I'll be like oh come on
like you know let's go watch you know TV
show or something for like an hour and
then we'll watch something and then
right afterwards she'll pull out the
iPad or something and be like
[Laughter]
I always wonder like like when is it
gonna slow down like what other I don't
know businesses are they gonna extend
that whole tipping thing too it's smog
test it's even on YouTube now have you
seen the tip feature on YouTube yeah
what yeah yeah you can turn it on I
recommend turning it on your channel
every now and then people will send you
a tip and I get a notification on my
phone that like so-and-so's tip and you
could tip anything from like a dollar to
I don't know a few hundred but when I
see that little tip feature I'm like you
know usually it's with a comment then
I'll respond back but yeah I just
thought of the next level business idea
what so when I invoice Graham I'm just
gonna do it in person and I'm gonna do
it safely and you know what he knows me
so so I'm gonna judge him based on it
and I'm gonna make the middle one like
52 yeah it's gonna be on it's I'm
turning the camera turn the camera on on
the screen too so you can see his
reaction yeah it's it's gonna be on um
on paychecks too I guarantee like no
they'll find a way to give that to
employers
rate though is that not a bonus bonus
seems too formal but a tip seems like
hey you did a good job this week let me
uh that's a bonus I think when I think
bonus I think of a performance bonus or
I think end of year bonus or like
something like that
but I think just on if let's say you're
paid every other week you wouldn't get a
bonus every other week it's just yeah I
don't know I could see this extending
it's like a relaxed bonus for sure yeah
an informal bonus but a bonus I feel
like is something you would expect or
work towards yeah I wouldn't be
surprised honestly at this point yeah
you know but I mean businesses are more
and more every year businesses are kind
of getting more
uh I feel like picked apart in a way
which for the good and maybe not for the
good at the same time I don't know I
don't know if you have an opinion on
that I feel like with Twitter
um being what it is I just feel like
businesses are kind of being pushed more
to be more ethical and better in many
good ways but then there's other
elements where I'm like why is anyone
even talking about this just like go
[ __ ] get a job
go you know what I mean or I don't know
give me an example I don't know I don't
know I've seen some of the Drew Gooden
was it drew good news talking about the
the Twitter Wars between companies
oh I never saw that yeah basically
companies like um Taco Bell were getting
in arguments with like Del Taco over
like this stuff on Twitter I think it's
hilarious Home Depot will be I think
that's what he's talking about what are
you thinking what am I thinking about
yeah what are you talking about you were
talking about like companies trying to I
mean how do I put this no I was thinking
I was thinking broad stroke from like uh
yeah from like employee to company
rather than a company we're talking
about different things yeah yeah yeah so
well because we were wait what were we
originally talking about that I that I
leaned into this uh tipping
yeah so like you're talking about bonus
structure tipping and all these
different things I feel like in general
from a society standpoint because of
like Twitter there's a lot of
conversation around like trying to be
more ethical and being better for you
know the people yeah and being less
geared towards you know these Mass
monopolies and how do we make people's
lives better which I think is good and
important it's just like but there's
sometimes you see a tweet where you're
just like I don't know about that like
that seems like it's not a good addition
to the club and so when you start
talking about like tipping here tipping
there it's like at what point do we draw
the line you know what I mean is it
going to be drawn at
thank you so much for my ibuprofen
the receipt's going to be that long yeah
yeah somehow they'll find a way to make
it longer I don't know I don't think
there's ever going to be a line that's
drawn I think it's constantly going to
be pushed and moved around and it's just
gonna be whatever the general sentiment
is at the time I think people they're
getting to the breaking point because
people are finally starting to talk
about the that's true the Tipping thing
now it's starting to happen good point
yeah and uh I think that there will be
an uprising a tipping Revolution so you
mean more tipping or or or I think
people are going to be like no more tips
like no like like tipping where tipping
is reasonable yeah the thing is like if
I check out uh it doesn't happen at
Starbucks but some like you know I get
an acai Bowl Starbucks now does tipping
they do yeah
yeah yeah but no um I don't know I think
I think that there will be an uprising
and people will be like okay I'm not
gonna do this anymore
yeah at least where it's it's uh you
know not not necessarily like people
aren't performing a long service for you
but you know what everywhere you go
people provide a service like imagine
going to your doctor's office and you
have a tip thing oh my God it's just
it's everything is a service for a tip I
would lose my mind just perform the
surgery how happy were you with your
service yeah yeah but they asked for the
tip beforehand yeah doc you make 500 000
a year I'm not tipping you sorry it's
just weird how like an acai Bowl could
be a 25 tip and that's like the middle
button right and then you go to a
restaurant the person's literally
serving You Porn doing all this stuff
and the difference in service is just
like crazy yeah but and although yeah
sure the price of the acai Bowls the
actual monetary gain for the percentage
Yeah but it's the same percentage Yeah
which for me effort doesn't really make
sense it's effort it's effort and time
yeah and time like and a waiter or
waitress is serving you for an hour at
least this is uh uh some you know I I
here's the thing I don't want to say
anything that would make it feel like
a service uh somebody working in service
doesn't deserve to make more money I
think they need more money I think it's
good I think tipping is good and I want
them to get tipped but it's like it's
not really being measured appropriately
is what I think or at least accurately
why not like 5 10 you know 15 12 or
something like that but then again the
price is lower though that's the other
thing but the service is lower
that's true but the ultimate tip is also
going to be lower every time if you go
to well I guess maybe not with a coffee
shops 20 bucks yeah yeah yeah I don't
know I feel like you could probably
generate potentially more in a coffee
shop because there's a line it's just
like boom boom boom boom boom I think
what would make sense is if the tips
were pooled and they went to everybody
then it might feel better but I feel
like the tips
with restaurants that are the biggest
problem is that they go to one person
they didn't your restaurants they didn't
tip out the buses and whatnot did I
always assumed it they actually tipped
the kitchen no so in mind that the chefs
would get tipped as well as actually
they were the only people that worked in
the restaurant that got paid higher than
minimum wage the chefs at my restaurant
not the ones that I worked at
interesting yeah there was no tipping
for that as far as I remember I I don't
ever remember being tipped but there are
more places doing it there are new
restaurants that are actually having
chefs be waiters at the same time they
would cook their food and then they
would run food and then they would get
tipped out so they'd get their their
salary or hourly and then they would get
tipped out as well that's got to be so
stressful if you're good dancing both
okay
well usually it's with the way that you
systematize the line and everything like
you basically switch off I think I've
never worked in a restaurant like that
but I've heard about it so I'm not sure
how the full system works but it's cool
yeah make more money yeah so I just have
two things to say here before we we wrap
up the episode the first I just want to
thank Lexar my official card sponsor
what happens
take the card out of my camera
I did yes what why do you think why is
it missing because you're the only
person who takes cards out of cameras
around it uh no Jack don't you dare try
it again with my card in that camera my
fam I had myself anyway somebody took my
Lexar card I'm gonna be asking Max art
if they would send me another one but
I'll take another one I want one too
sorry Alexa you want a Lexar card Josh
yeah sure oh okay sure so anyway thank
you Lexar but the next thing that I want
to mention is uh Josh actually during
this podcast
um I actually
thought of the perfect
um uh Christmas gift for my wife so I
ordered your cookbook oh yeah coming
today but if she asks you gave it to me
on this podcast and it was a gift
because I'm not trying to send any mixed
messages okay so I just need you to back
me up on that okay it would have been
amazing hey would you have been able to
sign it yes yes why don't you do this
you can keep that book and then I'll
send all you guys books oh my gosh that
would be great done that would be cool
that would be amazing yeah be happy
thank you thank you so much I also have
some bankroll coffee for you too yeah
we'll link to your info uh in the
description along with your cookbook I'm
excited to get that yeah it'll be fun
you guys will get I'll send a little
couple things so you guys send you some
salt
you know what I could get uh Nick
digiovanni's salt oh no no no no no no
no no no what's that no you got your own
song well now I have to make my own salt
for you man come on come on come on
Nick's a good guy he's a sweet guy so
huh what do you think of him he's a good
guy yeah
well I mean I don't know Nick's
background to be honest
um I don't I don't know I mean he's a
Master Chef he was one of the finalists
I know that yeah yeah I don't know what
restaurants he worked at though
um but I know that he I think he's
cooked in food before but I met him once
and we had a we had a really good time
we like chatted for a little bit you
should be doing a collab with him I
think that blow up the internet yeah see
imagine YouTube going uh going off
against uh Gordon Ramsay and he's the
one who like taste tests the food yeah
that'd be fun no you gotta include all
the guys you gotta have googa you gotta
have babish yeah all those guys yeah all
competing for this like the Marvel
universe that would be a Matt Stoney
eating it yeah that would be insane Matt
Stoney passes away
amazing yeah well thank you guys for
having me on the phone thank you Tony
appreciate it thank you guys so much
make sure to get your free stuff down in
the description public.com wow their
sponsor usually speak over each other
yes all the time yeah guys follow me on
Instagram real quick thank you so much
episode when people are shouting out
stuff we always interrupt the other
person shouting out